[Music]
hey everyone i'm julian trio and i'm a
customer engineer at google cloud and
welcome back to the google cloud
technical guides for startups where we
are creating a series of videos for
technical enablement to help startups to
start build and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably on google
cloud
in our previous episode we showed you
how you can get started on google cloud
today we'll be moving on to our third
stop streamlining application
development
we'll be covering first the basics of
what exactly is serverless and following
that i'll be introducing to you the
portfolio of solutions available and
when to choose which i'll then share
with you a little bit more about cloud
run and also run through a demo as well
right after i'll be sharing with you
some tips on how you can optimize both
performance as well as cost and last but
not least we'll be running through a
sample application of an e-commerce
platform together as well as a customer
case study we'll then wrap up with some
of the links that you can follow up with
right after this video so come on now
let's explore the land of the serverless
together
first of all we need to get our basics
right what does serverless mean when you
make use of a serverless infrastructure
it means that you're able to deploy and
scale your applications more quickly and
securely in a fully managed environment
this also means that your developers can
focus on writing the code instead of
having to worry about the infrastructure
this leads to faster time to market
which is definitely important for
startups on top of that your workloads
will automatically scale according to
the traffic and you only need to pay for
what you consume
all in all this enables faster and more
secure development deployment as well as
operations
now that we have the basics sorted out
let me share with you how google cloud
can help you to streamline your
application development so first up we
have cloud run now cloud run is really
great for running any form of
applications or containers in a fully
managed environment
next we have cloud functions which is
definitely great for any event driven
applications and last but not least we
have app engine which also can help to
run applications in a fully managed
environment
i'm pretty sure you must be wondering
when to choose which well i've got your
back here are some of the most common
use cases being compiled together for
you to help you with your product
decision making and now we're going to
zoom in to the latest edition as well as
a very popular one which is cloud run
cloud run enables you to run your
containerized applications on a managed
compute platform quickly and securely
bringing you from containers to
production within seconds
write your code your way using your
favorite languages such as python ruby
go and many more not only that with
cloud run you only have to pay for the
resources that your startup consumes and
this means that you won't have to pay
for over provisioned resources cloud run
is also built upon the open standard k
native which ensures the portability of
your applications
and all of the above allows you to build
your applications the way you want to
right it's about time to give you a tour
now on to the demo
in this demonstration we'll be creating
a cloud run service with the use of a
container image being built we'll then
explore versioning as well as traffic
splitting now for today we'll be making
use of a sample application which is a
simple meme generator service how it
works is that it takes in an upper text
a bottom text as well as an image in the
url bar in order to create a meme
now you can follow along with your own
application or make use of a sample one
in the description box below
alright let's jump into the first two
sections
first let's begin by taking a look at
the application code here you can see
the application code and remember that
you can code in any of your favorite
languages such as python ruby go and
many more
and over here we can see the meme
generator service works by first taking
in a upper text a bottom text as well as
an image url in order to create and
generate a meme
and next over here we also have a
dockerfile that defines the base image
where it's all being packaged into a
container next i'm going to show you how
easy it is to build the container image
by using the builds command
all right we're going to speed this up
part a little bit until it's being done
and now it's done and now we're gonna
deploy this onto cloud run
all right now we're gonna navigate over
to cloud run
and here we are right now in cloud run
and to create a new cloud run service
you can simply click on the create
service button and over here you can
give your service a name select the
region as well as select the container
image that you want to deploy in this
case we'll be selecting the container
image that we have just built
following that you can just click on
create in order to deploy
now we have our container image running
on cloud run
and here we have our application up and
running
as you can see you have all of the
information that you may need right at
your fingertips from the managing of
your revisions which we'll get into
shortly metrics logs and many more
making it really easy for your startup
to manage
and right now we're going to check out
our application simply by clicking on
the url
and here we can see that our service is
up and running
we can simply click on an example to see
how the application works
and now we're going to test it out too
simply by adding in and editing the
upper text bottom text as well as image
url to generate a new meme
and there we have it
next i'm gonna show you how easy it is
to deploy a new version of the
application
alright so now we're gonna head back to
the application code and edit it a
little by including a hello as well as a
welcome message
we're going to quickly click save
and once we're done we're going to
rebuild this container image
we're going to split this part up a
little until the container image is
being built as well
and we're done
and now we're gonna head back to cloud
run and redeploy this new revision
as you can see it's really simple and
you can easily select the latest
container image that you have just built
and deploy
and immediately we're done
you can see that we have our new version
now up and running on cloud run
now moving on to the third part of our
demo what if you wanted different
versions to serve different levels of
traffic let's take a final look at
traffic splitting
with cloud run it is extremely easy to
manage your traffic for the different
revisions that you may have
simply click on manage traffic and over
here you can fill out the form to the
different levels of desired traffic for
your different revisions
and with that we are done with the demo
over here you saw how easy it was to not
only deploy on cloud run but to also
manage your revisions as well as manage
your traffic
now you may wonder what are the most
important things to take note of for
cost as well as performance in this
section we'll be covering the best
practices for cost optimization as well
as performance optimization i'll be
putting some links in the description
box below as well for your further
reading to optimize performance first of
all remember to specify the minimum
number of container instances you want
to be kept warm and ready to serve
requests secondly don't forget to also
try to minimize the number of
dependencies as well as the size of them
to make sure that your service is a lean
one thirdly lazily load code which is
infrequently being used if your language
supports it and also make use of global
variables as well
the initialization of global variables
occurs during the startup which can
severely increase the code start time
now one great example of a variable that
is expensive to initialize will be the
database connections database
connections are great to keep as global
variables
and finally make use of minimal
container images larger container images
can increase your security
vulnerabilities and this is because they
contain more than what your code needs
as for cost optimization setting the
right number of maximum instances
depending on your traffic as well as
desired level of request latency can
help you to optimize your overall cost
secondly it is also important to take
note and optimize your cpu as well as
ram
cpu usage is generally a huge
contributor towards your overall costs
thirdly it is also highly important to
make use of billing alerts as well as
labels
budget alerts provide an early warning
signal to unexpected increases in your
bill and as for labels labels allow you
to assign a simple text value to
particular resources and this allows you
to understand which are the most
significant contributors towards your
overall bill to allow you to take action
on them
on top of that implementing basic local
caching where a local in-memory copy of
frequently loaded or generated data is
being kept can produce significant and
dramatic improvements to both cost as
well as performance and last but not
least do not forget to always make sure
you measure the effectiveness of your
changes so that you can keep track of
them and continue to improve and
optimize the costs
now let's take a look at a fictitious
use case of a sample e-commerce
application
when an order is being first placed on
the front end which is being deployed on
cloud run cloud run receives the request
and sends it over to pubsub which is an
asynchronous messaging service the
subsequent microservices which are also
deployed on cloud run can then subscribe
to these pubsub events
these microservices can then make calls
to the other parts of the architecture
as you can see the examples over here
and if we wanted to take a look at a
real-life example we have errorbase ki
eravask ai provides ai driven asset
management and amongst other incredible
results they were able to reduce their
server costs with cloud run and not only
that they were also able to automate
infrastructure management resulting in
higher productivity
all in all google cloud is able to help
you with the streamlining of your
application development now i hope that
today's session has given you a good
understanding and overview as well as
how you can get started
and after this video if you are keen to
find out more and you cannot get enough
of application development feel free to
check out the suggestions here as well
as the links in the description below
and in the next episode you will be able
to learn more about containerization
how to deploy on the google kubernetes
engine
optimization of performance as well as
look through a sample architecture as
well as a customer case study alright
and that's a wrap for today see you in
the next video
[Music]